hi this is presh talwalkar and in the
next few videos we're going to discuss
game theory in the tv series breaking
bad
we'll get started by discussing what
exactly game theory is specifically
we're going to compare decision theory
which is static to game theory which is
dynamic
the general idea in decision theory is
that given a list of data or given a set
of circumstances you want to make the
best possible decision
game theory is much like that but it's
dynamic you can't just say the data is
given
what you do will affect how others will
react so you need to think strategically
and anticipate how others will react to
make the best decision
a very simple example of this is in
decision theory you know you might look
at the weather forecast and say well the
weather looks nice so i you know the
best decision is to go to the beach
but in game theory you're going to think
that well if the weather is nice
others are also going to think the
weather is nice they're also going to go
to the beach so you have to think
strategically that you'll go to the
beach earlier in the day when other
people aren't there
and now we'll get to how this relates to
breaking bad
is that the decision theory way of going
about it is that walt would just say
i need to make money so i'm going to
sell drugs
well quickly learns that he needs to use
game theory
that he realizes he's going to make
enemies while selling drugs and he's
going to have to think strategically to
stay ahead of them
one of the first scenes which sets this
up is in episode 3.
walt has there's crazy 8 has tried to
kill walt and jesse
and so walt has taken him hostage
he's now back at home and he's deciding
what to do
this scene
shows walt's thought process
so let's analyze the scene
one very important thing is that walt
makes a list which has a left side which
is all decision theory and right side
which is all game theory
the left side was all about morality
guilt principles taking data trying to
make the best possible decision
the right side of the list which only
had one item which was the repercussions
if he lets crazy eight live
walt realizes that if he lets crazy it
live
then crazy eight's probably going to
kill him and all his family
the only way to go about this is that
walt knows what he has to do
i hope you liked this first video please
keep watching the rest of the series and
please subscribe to my channel
you can also catch me on my blog mind
your decisions or on twitter at
preshtalwalker